los restos de un posible desaparecido
durante la dictadura Cívico militar
ocurrida en Uruguay entre
1973 y 1985 fueron hallados dentro del
Batallón número 14 del ejército uruguayo
en las afueras de Montevideo según
informaron Fuentes oficiales el
presidente del Instituto Nacional de
Derechos Humanos informó que se encontró
al menos un cráneo y restos óseos esto
lo dijo en rueda de prensa Este martes
donde también Indicó que llevará al
menos 48 horas
dilucidar si se encuentran más restos
humanos dentro del Batallón y varios
días más identificar los ya hallados
el Instituto realiza excavaciones en el
lugar por parte de un grupo de
antropólogos
la asociación de madres y familiares de
desaparecidos durante la dictadura
uruguaya Fueron informados por medio del
fiscal de crímenes de lesa humanidad y
también por el Instituto Nacional de
Derechos Humanos de confirmarse que se
trata de los restos de un desaparecido
sería uno de las 197 personas detenidas
desaparecidas durante la dictadura en
Uruguay bajo el marco del plan represivo
denominado plan Cóndor impulsado por
Estados Unidos en Latinoamérica en los
años
70 y 80 de confirmarse el hallazgo este
sería el quinto ocurrido en el país